Bob discovered something very interesting
while making multi-coloured ear rings out of beads for his store.
Now his customers like variety
so he decides to make every possible style for each size.
Starting with size 3, he begins
by figuring out all possible styles.
Each earring begins as a string of beads
and then the ends are attached to form a ring.
So first, how many possible strings are there?
Well, with 2 colours and 3 beads, there are 3 choices,
each from two colours.
So, 2 x 2 x 2 = 8 possible unique strings.
Then he subtracts the strings which have only one colour.
or mono-coloured strings
since he is only building multi-coloured earrings.
Then he glues them all together to form rings.
He was assuming he would end up with six different earrings
but something happened:
he can no longer tell the difference between most of them.
It turns out he has only two styles
because each style is now part of a group with 2 identical partners!
Notice you can always match them up
based on rotations.
So the size of these groups must be based
on how many rotations it takes
to return to the original.
Or: how many rotations to complete a cycle.
So this means that the original set
of multi-coloured strings
divides evenly into groups of size 3.
Hm. Now, would this be true for other sizes?
That would be convenient,
since he always wants the same amount of each style.
So he tries this with four beads.
First, he builds all possible strings
and with 4 beads he can choose from 2 colours for each bead,
so 2 x 2 x 2 x 2 = 16.
Then he removes the two mono-coloured necklaces,
and attaches all of the others to form rings.
Now, will they form equal-sized groups?
Apparently not!
What happened?
Notice how the initial set of strings
devides into styles.
If strings are of the same style,
it means that you can form one into the other
simply by grabbing beads from one end,
and sticking them onto the other end.
There is one style which has only two members.
This is because it is built out of
a repeating unit of length 2,
so only two rotations are required to complete a cycle
Therefore, this group only contains two.
He cannot split them into an equal number of styles.
What about size 5?
Will they break into an equal number of each style?
Wait! Suddenly he realises he does not need to build them
in order to find out! It must work,
since 5 cannot be made up of a repeating pattern,
because 5 cannot be broken into equal parts.
It's a prime number.
So, no matter what kind of multi-coloured string
you start with,
it will always take five rotations
or bead swaps, to return to itself.
The cycle length of every string must be five.
Well, let's check.
First, we'll build all possible strings,
and remove the two mono-coloured strings.
Then we separate the strings into groups
which belong to the same style
and build a single earring for each style.
Notic that each earring rotates exactly 5 times
to complete a cycle.
Therefore, if we glue all the strings into rings,
they must split into equal-sized groups
of five.
But then he goes a step further.
Currently he is only using two colours,
but he realises this must hold with any number of colours.
Because any multi-coloured ring with a prime number of beads P
must have a cycle lenght of P
since primes cannot be broken into equal-sized units.
But if a composite number of beads are used
such as 6, he will allways have certain strings
with shorter cycle lengths
since it is built out of a repeating unit
and therefore will form smaller groups.
And amazingly, he just stumbled on to Fermat's Little Theorem.
Given A colours
ands strings of length P which are prime
the number of possible strings
is a x a x a, p times, or
a to the power of p
And when he removed the mono-coloured strings
he subtracts exactly a strings
since there are one for each colour.
This leaves him with (a^p)-a strings
And when he glues these strings together
they will fall into groups of size p
since each ring must have a cycle length of p
Therefore, p divides a^p-a
And that's it!
We can express this statement in modular arithmetic too
Think of it, if you divide a^p by p
you will be left with a remainder a
So we can write this as
And here we have stumbled on to
one of the fundamental number results in number theory,
merely by playing with beads.